cette attaque meurtrière à anis et nous
accueillons maintenant en direct sur
europe 1 françois bayrou président du
modem et maire de pau bonjour monsieur
bayrou on a entendu beaucoup de
réactions et je vais vous en livrer une
pour commencer après votre votre émotion
c'est celle d'alain juppé
si tous les moyens avaient été pris
dit-il l'attentât de nice on n'aurait
pas eu lieu
cette phrase elle est terrible la
terrible à entendre êtes vous d'accord
avec ces propos françois bâillon écouter
chacun s'exprime comme il le sent moi je
ne veux pas faire de polémique à propos
de ce qui se passe je me suis toujours
interdit d'en faire quels que soient les
gouvernements
quelles que soient les circonstances et
quelles que soient les positions des uns
et des autres pourquoi parce que je
pense que dans le moment nous sommes on
a le plus grand besoin de solides
j'allais dire de solidité nationale et
solidité ça veut évidemment dire aussi
solidarité je trouve que bien sûr il ya
des décisions à prendre bien sûr il ya
des améliorations à apporter je vais
vous en proposer une très importante
dans quelques minutes mais vous voyez
bien que à partir du moment où on
transforme en polémique la situation
telle qu'elle est créé évidemment on est
on affaiblit la réponse possible donc
chacun encore une fois s'exprime comme
il le sent moi j'ai été frappé parce que
la commission d' enquête parlementaire a
dit et je pense qu'il faut écouter les
recommandations qui sont les siennes
voulait dire par exemple rassemblé tous
les services de renseignements de
coordination
alors je veux dire une chose très
précises et qui me semble-t-il est
extrêmement éclairantes
si vous regardez le parcours de tous
ceux qui ont provoqué ces crimes commis
ces crimes
alors vous remarquez qu'ils se
ressemblent tous il ya une incroyable
similitudes entre les profils et les
parcours personnel de tous ceux qui
tombent dans cette horreur qui cause
cette horreur ces criminels qui cause de
cet homme nous avons encore très peu
d'informations sur le chauffeur est mais
je vais je vais vous dire enfin il me
semble d'après les informations que vous
avez vous-même indiqué il ya une minute
c'est toujours le même profil c'est des
délinquants des hommes délinquants
jeunes qui tombent de la délinquance
générale dans cette folie de deux
meurtres et de suicide parce que ils
veulent tuer et se faire tuer il cherche
les deux en même temps
et si vous réfléchissez à ça alors vous
vous rendez compte que en croisant les
informations sur les parcours des uns et
des autres sur leur délinquance et sur
leur radicalisation alors probablement y
at il de quoi nourrir des services de
renseignement unifiée je crois qu'ils
sont trop divisés pour l'instant les
services sont de la formation passe plus
ou moins bien les services ont plus ou
moins séparés les uns des autres parfois
en concurrence les uns avec les autres
et si on line hi fi tous ces services de
renseignement avec à l'idée que les
critères qui indique qu'il y à risque de
tomber dans dans ce dans ces crimes sont
éloquents et donc on a là me semble-t-il
une ligne 2 d'amélioration de
progression dans la prévention romandie
sous françois bayrou quand certains
disent on ne peut pas surveiller chacun
parce qu'en l'occurrence cet individu
n'était pas fiché est-ce donc pas pour
radicalisation à ce moment là vous dites
vous précisément qu'il faut encore qu'on
se donne les moyens qu'on essaye en tout
cas d'organiser nos services de les
unifier pour les traquer contre toulon
je veux je veux dire de la manière la
plus claire que moi je refuse un constat
d'impuissance
l'idée qu'on ne pourrait pas faire
différemment on ne pourrait pas faire
mieux ou on ne saurait pas où c'est trop
difficile où ça coûterait trop cher est
une idée qui n'est pas recevable
lorsqu'il s'agit de dizaines centaines
maintenant de vies humaines qui sont
brisées et d'assassinât sur notre sol et
vous revenez aux parents sabayon
accepter cela le discours suivant
c'est-à-dire intégré ce risque
aujourd'hui est ce basculement de nos
sociétés qui doit nous faire accepter ce
risque et donc d'accepter aussi de
limiter notre liberté au profit de notre
sécurité
la conscience du risque elle est
indispensable pour la mobilisation de
tous parce que à ce que je viens de dire
las de l'unification des services de
renseignement pour que les populations
qui présente ces critères de risque soit
identifiée et suivie est repérée à
l'avance fois d'ajouter une deuxième
c'est que tous ces gens là ils ont des
voisins un entourage des cousins des
proches et si il existe dans leur
voisinage et dans les quartiers
cette conscience du risque
alors il peut y avoir aussi alerte et
quand ils y alertes ont sauvé des
dizaines de vies humaines et en sort du
cauchemar dans lequel tout le monde
tombe et n'auront nous revenons nous
revenons à la formule près préalable que
vous aviez c'est à dire la nécessité de
fer blanc
les mots de manuel valls avec lesquels
vous communier françois bayrou merci
beaucoup pour cette intervention sur
europe 1 nous sommes au coeur de cette
édition spéciale